hallo mein name ist steigend wie das
mittagessen hochgekommen mein name ist
luca und wir spielen heute einige mlg
simulators ich denke das video wird
scheiße also am besten jetzt schon
wieder wegklicken dieses spiel heißt mlg
simulator handel für suntech trade piste
mode beta das ist auf jeden fall ein
supercooler name wir sind hier ein typ
mit einer war
wo ist jetzt von unserem körper
unser ziel ist es dieses okay wir müssen
dieses land hier abschließend
ich war wir spielen einfach mal weiter
also hier sind wieder einige sniper ab
ich habe angst vor diesem spiel keinen
sinn ich schiesst direkt auf ihn drauf
bei meiner mama was soll das da oben
ich schieße die ganze zeit mountain view
und diese takko welt ab und alles aber
es geht nicht wieso steht doch einfach
das wm team nummer eins aber wir spielen
natürlich direkt schon weiter als
teenager teil 2 hier haben jetzt eine
snipern der hand er ist ähnlich
anspruchsvoll und wir müssen hier mario
abschließen und dann
viel ist langweilig wir brauchen einen
neuen simulator hier ist eine newtown
diese ganzen dafür alles zu viel wird
zum lade pilze scheiße das problem ist
die sind aber auch alle gleich auf
dieser scheiß website alle dinge alessio
hier ist etwas was vielleicht ein
bisschen anders sein könnte
ich entschuldige mich an dieser stelle
für dieses video das kann nicht sagen ob
ich da nie in die mitte doch mal was
davon okay hier ist was mit minecraft
das ist aber
es ist tatsächlich alles der gleiche
scheiß es ist es ist alles der gleiche
scheiß wer entwickelt so eine vielleicht
dass dieser hier ein bisschen anders
es sind einfach nur einfach andere nur
ich bin nur ich glaube ich habe
nee ich hab kein besseres spiel gefunden
oh mein gott ich habe mir gerade extra
sonnenschein anderen simulator
runtergeladen und was kommt
wittmaack as a ein sex funktioniert ich
mir war die stadt noch mal was passiert
wenn ich auf ausführung clique es stürzt
ab angeblich kann ich irgendwo auswählen
dass das einen kompatibilitätsmodus
machen soll aber diese funktion gibt es
irgendwie nicht
das ist das dümmste video was ich hier
hochgeladen habe wenn es euch vielleicht
trotzdem gefallen hat würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freund ich denke es
hat euch nicht gefallen ich bin einfach
wenn ihr einen guten simulator kennt
dann schreibt sie mir doch bitte in die
kommentare ich habe glaube ich wenn ihr
das video seht nicht wahrscheinlich
wieder trotzdem sehr viel arbeit im
schnitt gegeben
ich bin tut mir leid